do you think a documentary such as crumb
would have the same appeal as it did
back in the 90s as it does now knowing
that that things have changed anybody
can have access to iMovie ten-year-olds
or teaching people on YouTube how to
edit creme was a brilliant documentary I
wouldn't change one frame of crumb if I
released it today it's the thing about
any of these documentaries is it's about
storytelling I don't care how fast you
cut or how you shoot it or what you
shoot it on creme was beautifully made
had told a great story was well
constructed and that's that's another
thing that people ask in these classes
is and they need to understand is that
the essence of any of this is
storytelling it's it's not about kind of
nothing you know all the other stuff is
great and will have an impact on the
film but you have to be telling a
compelling story Krum had a beginning a
middle and an end
absolutely fascinating characters great
lead character so I you know I wouldn't
change one bit of crime and I think it
would be just as successful and
obviously he went on to do feature films
he had the chops
he had the storytelling chops to go on
and do feature films that being said
Kevin what is a three act structure for
documentary film isn't that manipulating
reality in some sense um yes and no I
mean um all storytelling you know this
was a a lesson that I was taught one
time I was in a meeting with Peter Guber
and I was pitching a show and I think he
was preparing his book tell to win which
is about what he calls the emotional
transportation business and he's his
claim I think it's true is that all
entertainment whether it's a documentary
or a commercial or a feature film
dramatic film the audience expects to be
taken from one point when they walk into
the theatre or turn on the TV to another
place into a final place at the end they
want to go on a ride somewhere and so
all filmmakers I think oh it to their
audience to tell some kind of story that
has a beginning middle and an end so
whether you construct it consciously or
not you just you when you think about it
all stories whatever you do the story of
you coming over here to talk to me today
I mean that has a beginning a middle and
that's just the way we do things so I
don't think you're constructing anything
if you following a character and you
meet them and you're you're doing this
film for some reason you find an
interesting character and here's where
they are at well if you follow them for
any length of time you're going to see
their life change and maybe maybe
they're trying to get something when you
meet them that's why you're interested
them interested in them in the beginning
so in act 2 they're going to be trying
to get that object and perhaps at the
end of two yes or no you know they'll
either get it or they'll come up against
something that they might not be able to
surmount in act 3 you're going to see
whether they get it or not in in border
war I had five main characters and each
of them I can eat of them had three acts
and this was just by being around them
for a certain amount of time there was a
young woman I followed she had lost her
husband who was a LA County deputy
sheriff he had pulled over a man on the
freeway the man shot him and killed him
he was an illegal immigrant he fled back
to Mexico so this young woman deaths Act
one for her Act two is she's trying to
find this man and I caught up with her
during act two and during the course of
six months I see her try every avenue
including writing the president United
States and meeting with him to try to
bring this guy back from Mexico to get
justice for her family and for her
husband Act three just a stroke of
fortune during our filming time they
actually found the guy in Mexico and
brought him back so that was her Act
three and completely unconstructed by me
but something that fits in that three
act structure and I was able to find
those three acts even in very very small
ways for these other characters you
might not think they were three acts but
they're actually three x somebody else
was a border agent who in the beginning
I see him do his job luma Haida the
crisis at the end of Act two is he
actually gets assaulted by a vehicle
that's a vehicular assault on a federal
agent by a coyote a human smuggler and
Act three they find out who the guy is
so that was another three act org so
you'll find these things in life as you
follow characters around and create
documentaries you'll find your extract
Cheers and weather and unconstructed or
documentaries and ones that you actually
construct yes you actually will make
them in the fog of war again l morris is
asked asking Robert McNamara to tell the
story but Morris knows when he's telling
the story that there is a beginning in
the middle and an end and McNamara knows
it too when he tells the story of his
involvement with the Vietnam War so you
know beginning his involvement what
happened during the war and what he
thinks about it now that's three acts so
I think you could find them surprisingly
in almost any scenario
you